améliorer et rénover son habitat oui
mais pas n'importe comment on peut
commencer par l'extérieur et regarder
l'isolation les tarifs énergétiques de
plus en plus élevés motive les
particuliers avec les facteurs
augmentant dit pas quelles sont les
solutions pour au caire au moins stopper
l'augmentation pas forcément payer moins
cher mais au moins cela veut dire le
recours à l'isolation est une demande
croissante depuis une dizaine d'années
le fait de justement isolé par
l'extérieur nos habitations vont nous
permettre d'apporter protection des
façades donc un assainissement des
façades qui ont souffert depuis ces
longues années et notamment forcément
une isolation efficace et durable de
l'habitation d'un violent liège autre
tendance le recours aux matériaux
naturels et écologiques
mon critère de choix il est simple c'est
que c'est plus naturel et c'est plus ça
correspond à ce qui s'est passé depuis
des années des centaines et des milliers
d'années donc revenir justaret ce que
veut la tradition et et parce que la
tradition c'est bon et derrière la
tradition de matériaux performants qui
ne sont pas forcément les plus chers il
ya une prime supplémentaire pour les
matériaux biosourcés que l'on n'avait
pas l'année dernière par exemple c'est
vraiment une nouveauté un avancement
dans tous les matériaux écologiques
après l'extérieur la tendance est à la
rénovation intérieure
le recours à des professionnels s'impose
parfois pour mettre ses idées en ordre
peut réussir aujourd'hui avec tout ce
qui se présente à nous comme matière
comme couleur comme com
je dirais comme mobilier autres et
objets déco on est capable de pouvoir
aujourd'hui faire de la déco et se
sentir bien chez soi même avec des
petits budgets
les tarifs débutent à 5000 euros environ
pour une rénovation par un architecte
d'intérieur
en france le marché de la rénovation
reprend depuis trois ans en constante
augmentation